boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don shotgun
we are still at Coe Fez the Congress on
the future of engineering software for
our second annual partnership with them
we are now sitting down with dr. Robert
graver hello hi thanks for coming on to
the show really being in it very excited
are you coming here all the way from
Germany yes um well headquarters in
Germany but you know I have a history in
the in the Bay Area so I love always
coming back here yes we the Bay Area
loves Germany we love you very much we
love cat very much which is a lot of
what you're focused on her and I also
focus on building serving so we'll be
talking about that to Robert's
background is very interesting he's now
been 18 years as the CTO at Graber also
prior to that did his PhD in civil and
environmental engineering at Stanford
doing energy management and commercial
real estate and impacts on building
energy performance so let's talk about
this on a on a on your journey
perspective so you know how did this all
how did your interest even in this
engineering and software get started
sure so I think even from a young age
was always interested in computers you
know gaming and but also trying to
figure out how everything worked my
father actually was about one of the
vase our very first entrepreneurs in the
sort of computing time so he that was
always a role model for me I basically
high school in Germany but left to go to
the UK when I was 16 I finished my high
school there and then a so the natural
progression was to kind of go for an
engineering a computing degree in London
and so that's what I did I ended up
doing a four-year degree in a master as
part of that my interest got sparked in
mobile devices so this is pre iPhone pre
Android the Windows Phone was just
starting at that time this is in 2000 or
19
and I was interested in saying is it
possible to bring engineering software
which was you know what we'd had worked
on in the company or my father's
business
would it be possible to have that work
in mobile right and so I took that as a
challenge and part of my sort of finally
a project was doing real-time graphics
on mobile devices and then seeing can we
take that even further and bring on a
full CAD system onto mobile and it's a
sort of my first real software project
was a cat's product and you mentioned
building surveying one of the questions
we asked ourselves why would you want to
do a CAD or mobile right viewing you
could even use a PDF or something simple
for that why would you want to have
access to the full CAD system and so
realized a lot of the jobs in which we
actually consume CAD or create cat have
to do with the physical world right
whether that's in constrain AC when you
actually you know you have physical
spaces that we're designing here so or
it's on the on the shop floor when
you're actually making the product and
so we realize there's no real point in
doing an architectural design package in
the field but doing a surveying package
makes a lot of sense because now you're
recreating the geometry form what's
actually in the physical world okay so
when you're when you're finding yourself
getting a first involved in engineering
your father is obviously this big role
model for your getting getting involved
and then you're you're starting to
figure out that yeah you're you're kind
of trying to position yourself somewhere
within CAD making it applicable to for
real-world scenarios like you know
building surveying making it easier for
you said to have cat on mobile yes and
this is somewhere where I don't think
I've really heard this quite yet yeah
cat on on a mobile device versus on your
desktop or laptop yeah what keep I mean
I wanna I want to hear more about the
reasons behind that but I want to also
have you explained post was this this
was at London when this was happening so
this is sort of at the tail end of my
my degree I was really interested in
this question about what's possible with
these mobile devices right there was the
first first device that went beyond the
flip phone they had a screen that touch
interface yes and so now for the first
time you could envision more
professional applications not just
telephoning and text messaging and so
that's something I explore with my with
the real-time graphics so I realize hey
there is something possible you can
actually really drive 3d graphics on
these devices you know I bought at a
small space but you could and so I
realized that if going back to Germany
and joining my father's business would
be a great way to explore that further
and that's what we did we created a
small team to start then building a
mobile CAD package a mobile CAD package
now but then you went to Stanford after
London so no I actually went to work for
eight years eight years before Wow so I
left academia completely went to work
explored some of these topics mobile we
then did a big project of rethinking of
how our desktop CAD should look like the
next generation of that that's something
I worked on for quite a number of years
and building out a team to support that
and then as part of covitz actually this
conference we got in touch with one of
the professors at Stanford who was
looking at the intersection of of civil
engineering and computation like how can
you use computational methods to to
drive change in the civil engineering
field Martin Fisher at Saifee which is a
certified integrated facility
engineering
and we basically start talking about
different topics that could be
interesting and over two or three years
having those conversation we would ask
maybe it's the best would be for me to
kind of join the ph.d program and I did
that in 2009 okay okay okay so then now
then before we get to the ph.d program
so when what were some of these in 2000
when you're putting together this team
at Graber what are you guys doing with
cad on mobile of course the computation
is so much less the power so much less
or a graphical capabilities so much less
back benefit so yes so we first have
obviously looked at sort of
visualization and and markup so one of
the things we and develop was the
ability to embed voice messages into
drawings so you take your drawing
outside you embed a voice message saying
I like you know you don't want to write
it down you don't have time so you just
make a voice as it instead of said it
being whatsapp whatever was actually
embedded in the design okay so not only
does it have you know your notes but
also has context and where exactly it
was referring to the same for pictures
and that was was was one use case the
other use case was really data
collection and so we have partners that
would build for example GPS tracking
software we embedded the software and
heavy machinery in the in the
construction field where there were just
terminals and we use a mobile cat to
really capture what was being done in
the field and the product that we build
ourselves was really all around this
idea of very efficient on-site planned
production of drawings of existing
buildings because Peters owners have
this problem that you know they design a
building
maybe the designs are even lost but the
building changes over time you need to
capture what's actually there either for
rental purposes for fire safety we did
lots of works in the in the UK
with big retail brands we did it with
the prison authority because they just
really need to get have up to date plans
and so that was sort of a part of our
business that we've always kept working
on because it was an ideal use case for
my wall cat okay okay so so one of one
of the one of the things is you know
when you're looking at kad's
capabilities back in 2000 you're
thinking about how to augment it make it
more effective for both on a
communication level between people that
are working on the same project as well
as make it more efficient for the
environments that it's being put into
like construction and leveraging already
some of the newer newer technologies
like sensor technologies GPS or so what
we're you know you and then you kept
teaching us that you were doing more of
this work in trying to add on to the on
to a CAD so then did it seem like there
was something that was like sticking as
you were adding things into CAD to make
it a better tool what were the things
that were that you were seeing most
people were wanting to see cab do you
get better at I think what we actually
realize is that the cat is an
interesting underlying fundamental
technology ready to create these designs
but we weren't necessarily working with
CAD users but the CAD user is a typical
person that sits in the office and you
know works with a large screen the
persons in the field is not a CAD user
typically it's a surveyor it is a maybe
somebody that's not that skilled and and
you know desktop computers and so we had
to really really rethink how we actually
interact how the user interacts with the
product make a much more workflow driven
then you know this open set of 500
features at any you can use it any order
no you have to go through step from 1 to
10 we've evolved that product line
actually over the last years into even
more sort of special specific niches and
one of those that we have today is the
kitchen survey market so it's a market
where in Germany the customer would go
to kitchen studio designers kitchen
with the seller but they won't produce
it until they've actually gone out to
verify that the measure that would
actually fit as details about where's
where where the outlets house the
windowsill position what kind of
materials are we looking at we and so we
would build a specialized solution and
somebody who is a trained kitchen
salesperson has no problem picking up
the software's understanding what is
required of em what measurement says you
have to take so fundamentally it's still
CAD but it's it's so much more of a
workflow driven tool and this is what
we've seen a always from the beginning
cadiz really like a fundamental building
block for a lot of engineering software
where the ideas you're presenting
geometry or you have and through the
specific applications you derive meaning
what that geometry actually represent
the screw is that a wall is it you know
something very different and that's why
so much engineering software builds on
top of Canada yeah when when when you're
when you're you're walking us through
this this really interesting realization
about how when someone's behind the
computer that is making the the CAD then
what ends up happening is the the person
in the field is typically not someone
that's making CAD the percent of fields
is so then you have to have this degree
of relatability x' for the person to
feel to be able to use cad in a way that
at least visually that makes sense and
then there's this whole that's becomes
this communication process and what then
what then was your big you know you
thought you talked about the stanford
professor that helped you get moving
into your into your ph.d program what
was that
you know what was that fire under you
that sparked you to also go and start
studying well i was obviously interested
in kind of exploring some questions a
little bit further that you know in an
economic you know a business context
it's a little bit harder to
to keep asking the why question at some
point you gotta deliver product that you
can sell to customers right and so I was
interesting has a completely different
environment to understand to drive a
little bit deeper and so I thought you
know my first conception when I arrived
at Sanford was like okay I'm gonna take
this building surveying specific
question and I really Drive little bit
deeper on that but through sort of
successive Y questions we ended up with
a very different or I ended up with a
very bit different PhD because I said
okay well why do we even measuring this
right so the first questions why why why
do you care about the data so then one
of the use cases we thought okay could
be for energy efficiency or energy
manner you want to understand how
efficient is this space so then we
started looking at okay well how precise
does the data need to be for it to
actually make a difference in the energy
calculation right so what degrees of
precision are we looking for is it
centimeters meat meters and you find out
very quickly that the the drawn which
really can vary by quite a lot for it
not to have a significant impact on the
energy so then the question is why do we
even go out to measure this and then the
question was why do we want to do an
energy model right why would you want to
what's interesting in that well you can
say well maybe I have a goal of reducing
the efficiency and then I kept doing
this and we kind of realized that's not
really a uniform approach to doing
energy management I could you know in
the corporate real estate specifically I
pick corporate real estate for one point
because it was large enough that actual
energy efficiency could make a big
dollar difference right you save 10% on
a you know a million dollar bill you're
saving money but is also close enough to
the core of the sort of the management
of the company so that's visible enough
that they could say well maybe it's
useful for us to do so and so sort of
studying different companies across the
US and I realized there's really very
high degrees of professionalism or their
different degrees of professionalism in
in that industry today
even a challenge of how to using this
the correct terminology or the same
terminology and so ended up really
thinking about what are the methods that
exists that they were the method a
potentially could make sense and do the
tools that I available really serve the
industry well and so I ended up I
started with saying I want to measure
spaces to basically saying well we all
be honest we need to first understand we
have to first generate a common language
and in common practices around how we're
going to deal with all this data that
we're producing and so from a very sort
of technical starting point we end up
with something that fundamentally was
really about talking to people
understanding how they work today yeah
the idea of taking taking a look at
something that seems to be a very common
theme like a commercial building and
being able to see it through a lens of
how can I make it better and not only
how can I make the tools better for the
engineers and designers but also how can
I make it more energy efficient these
are very important things to pass along
with the with the way of thinking to
younger people how can I make things
better than when I look around me how
can I design them to be better so then
did you end up experiencing success with
with with with changing the design of
buildings in order to decrease the
amount of cost of energy well I think I
think the point I was trying to make is
that my realization is just simply to
quantify is the building efficient is a
very complicated question and the second
question there's certain tools in the
market are supposed to help you
understand is your building efficient
but also is it building more efficient
and it was previously so you've changed
you've changed so the windows
potentially change the lights right yeah
is the ability actually more efficient
do you have a good tool for helping you
understand that and that's actually and
I'm not a very well and to address
problem at this point so like energy
expenditure so you can look at energy
expenditure but as variable factors that
impact that right
whether occupancy among other things
opening hours etc but you're the year
you can see that in like June with 2018
vers June of 2019 that that's usually
similar weather
well that so yes so the so we're getting
it's a little bit into the weeds right
now but these are also interesting we
yeah yeah yeah so the so you typically
use a normalization for that why do you
say this year we had this many heating
degree days and this year we maybe might
have had a different number so we know
in a normalized that because we don't
want to look at the bear consumption we
want to look at consumption normalizing
for weather mm-hmm right but then we
want to look at normalizing for weather
and occupancy yeah because you may have
gained employment by 10 yeah you might
know and then the question is okay now
let's put an example I add a 10 percent
staff means the HPC is running extra
hours to just kind of cool us down is
that the building managers fold right so
so these are these are these are real
questions right saying what are you
interested in what are you interesting
and measuring is interested in measuring
or interesting because then do you
measure per person there next yeah oh
yeah these are all relevant these are
all sort of questions you need to ask
yourself what your end goal is if you
and goal is to get a plaque on the on
the wall which is what some people want
to do we they want to dissimilar they
want to show that they care about the
energy efficiency then we have an energy
star player or whatever or is your goal
to
I'll figure out what how an efficient
building in your organization should
look like or do you want to figure out
the big picture designs of the future
yeah
and so the there's a lot of we ended up
doing realizing that why people do these
things why do people actually invest in
energy efficiency do they do it for very
many for different reasons
we had some companies that were that we
studied that really cared about the
dollars they wanted to save dollars and
if they could you know get a two-year
return on a lighting retrofit let's do
it
that's a great way to invest our money
but some companies that really only
cared about the messaging to customers
or their own employees saying look we
take care of this we care about the
environment and it just as you do and
we're going to take care of this one
examples of the space you're in yeah and
we have other companies that wanted to
show excellence
it was a custodian Bank and they were is
really hard for them to show their
customers that they are very deliberate
and thoughtful and how they you know
approach business and one way they could
show it is being very considerate about
how they manage processes around the
buildings and one of those was how do we
keep ever being more efficient in there
so the simple question where you say
what will save us money is this is too
simple yeah yeah and so that was part of
the research like it was right again I
was really I came from a computer
science background my interest was how
do I capture space efficiently how do I
capture energy efficiently without a net
without stepping back saying
why do we want to do this right and and
that's sort of like part of the joy of a
PhD is that you get kept getting these
questions and you're like well I don't
know let me go find out and and you keep
doing that until you get to a point
where you say well I think I've reached
a point where there's no consensus here
so maybe it's worthwhile to study this
part first before we even go down all
the way and saying well what are the
right tools for measuring buildings yeah
yeah it's cool that you bring up how the
different people have different ways of
perceiving the way that they are energy
efficient some people like you said get
a plaque some people tell their
employees some people tell their
customers some people want to
potentially build the next generation of
gardens on the rooftop solar panels on
the rooftops complete water recycling
systems all this kind of crazy things
and composting the food in the garden
all this crazy stuff that is fascinating
and that could potentially but yeah how
do you measure it for all the variables
this is this is really good good stuff
okay when you when you're when when
you're doing that and then you're
finding yourself moving your skin you're
still doing work with Graber while
you're doing the finishing up the the
PhD and and coming back to boss and sure
yeah so you know of course the great
with the business continued
you know and one of the things we did
during that time was quite asking
ourselves again
how do people want to use our software
right we talked about the desktop user
really being sort of somebody who spends
a lot of time with CAD but realizing
that it actually is CAD to some degrees
is also you know a communication tool
right the same as documents our
communication tool and how do we make
that again available to more people in
an organization and so with the arrival
of iOS and Android and we then brought
them bought new mobile CAD systems onto
those devices again to somebody who's
out in the construction site or somebody
is on the shop floor can take the
designs with them and then we actually
another Copas conversation and a couple
years ago I led to us working on a full
cloud-based cat system right and again
main driver for that is necessary as I
cool we can do it it's more about well
how do we access that user who's not
gonna install that you know big install
of cat software get licensing and all
that make all that setup now how do we
tell me how can I get shared design with
you so you can comment on it that you
can review and give me feedback on
without me having to set up something
very complicated right and sending out a
PDF serves that to some degree but I
have no way of getting that back if I
don't want you to give that to you
anymore I have no I've very little
control of the experience you're gonna
get half while you're viewing that and
so those are the things we can I you
know I was part of you know moving that
forward even during the PhD but of
course in a much reduced role as that
was really my focus and then what have
you been seeing then in in CAD and in
building surveying over the last it was
have been 10 years since the PhD I
finished any 15 or 16 so recently a
couple of year three years three years
yeah yeah since PhD
so what has it been like in the last you
know three years when you've been doing
some of the some more of the building
surveying and CAD at the cutting edge
what have you been seeing so CAD you
know when is quite diversified and what
kind of tools we're using so AC
computer-aided design versus mechanical
versus civil what we traditionally do
which is sort of you know we call 2d
kappa it's actually 2d and 3d but they
all slightly different paradigms and we
do see a lot of that growing together
right and you know you see more and more
design happening in in tools like Revit
SolidWorks sort of the name is two
leading products but there's still a
need to communicate again so our type of
tool which are drawing really drawing
tools to have that as a documentation
and legal contract and also a
communication tool continuously be
relevant but it becomes more more
relevant to be able to consume and work
with that other content you're teaching
about this earlier just that all these
platforms have their own exporting their
own systems now they all have their own
formats they all sort of traditionally
have proprietary file formats but
there's bigger push by the users to say
hey we got to figure out how to
collaborate here getting the different
functions of a business to work together
and so I think it's quite an interesting
time we've had you know this cloud shift
now happening for the last five years
and this is used to be leading industry
it's sort of a little bit more laggard
simply because of the large install base
of the sort of traditional desktop
applications but we're trying to also
enable some of our partners who
currently have finding a little bit hard
to kind of move to the cloud and mobile
like with our tools to make that a
little bit easier because we do believe
in they're in
and potential for enhanced capabilities
there yeah yeah so okay so assisting
some of your clients to make the
transition to to cloud and then is there
also a a is there a specific cat tool
that you find maximizes collaborative
capability well I don't want air so
there's obviously everybody's trying to
solve that problem in some way or form
right traditionally if you look at the
mechanical cat space you know you subsea
like the PDM systems of the world where
you know all the data would be managed
in one place but only one person could
check out that data at one point and
work with that right that's inherently
limiting because if you and I want to
make changes to the same part we it's
not possible right
and there was a lot of pain points there
and we're seeing more and more systems
now move towards sort of a more data
based type approach where everybody can
make changes and they all float together
into one sort of master of posit Ori and
it's more in the mechanical space today
excuse me and less in the AC spaces but
I see it they're also coming now so
those sort of common data are
environments where people all publish
the data together and I think that
fundamentally changes the collaboration
game because now I'm no longer limited
by
you know single access we can all access
together yeah our solutions for example
today already include abilities to share
view only links that you know not only
give you access to design but they're
also alive so whatever if I make a
change even after I've shared the the
design with you you will see the live
version right away and I think a super
powerful just to ease never having to
worry about am I looking at the latest
or am I looking at version 56 right and
I think it's just it gets enabled by
cloud mostly just the idea that you no
longer passing on files you you
basically have a central repository and
we're all looking at the same truth yeah
yeah interesting the central repository
seems to be the like one of the main
ways to make sure that the collaboration
has always had the final that you're
always collaborating on the final
product on the font of the edge and then
what about with with with building
surveying sure on that side of things so
building serving for us I think the main
changes now it used to be that you know
we would go out more our clients would
go out we really focused on selling that
software we go out and create a DWG S or
a classic drawing file what we're seeing
different so in the kitchen serving
market they don't care about that they
want the kitchen design to come back in
whatever planning software they using so
it's the deal which is sort of a nice
intermediate but they really care about
okay what does it mean it what what kind
of cabinet Deenie on what size right and
we're finding that now with the sort of
prevalence of BIM and 3d tools in the
ASU space more and more clients when I
say and we need to BIM model so that we
can provide our potential tenants or
potential buyer as a 3d virtual work
through a walkthrough environment
so the the needs have changed a little
bit over time and this is a major part
of potential like virtual and augmented
reality experiences these walkthroughs
and the building environments so there's
that that seems to be a reoccurring
theme from some of the clients that you
work with is that they want to to be
able to enter into their building
surveying with the tools it really
depends on what what your goals are
right I think for professional to look
at the drawing file it's very easy to
interpret okay this is the window this
is so this is a door right you know you
kind of even if you're not too familiar
you kind of understand what the
symbology means but this it gets very
technical very quickly like this is a
this is like a socket or this is you
know lighting fixture for example a 3d
environment is is richer in that it
actually makes it extremely obvious how
to navigate the space and what the
symbols mean because it's just it's a
much closer representation of our real
world that's right and so depending on
who your audience is like if you say I'm
gonna I want to use sort of giving a
potential tenant just a floor plan I'm
gonna give them you know a 3d model that
they can spin they can slice they can
look at gives them much better sense
okay what is the scale of those
properties if you do mash up with you
know one of the furniture vendors and
say well how would that look if I put it
bad in here right and so they are it
just opens it's sort of a game if
without that it's really hard to do
virtual reality and augmented reality
yeah but if you have that you can then
give people a way to experience the
space in a much more complete way that
with the 2d design is just so much
interpretive there that it's hard to do
that
what are you most looking forward to
engineering software converging and
moving towards I think on the
engineering side I would say that there
you know we've seen some first
developments with on shape and fusion
c60 and other cloud-based mechanical CAD
system that you know they're starting to
unlock some of those you know
collaborative and other features through
the cloud and I think it's just such a
key turning like thing you can do to
change what kind of software you can
architect that I think we're going to
see in the next five to ten years many
more solutions jumping on that and then
finally unlocking some of the
capabilities you know some of the very
obvious things is rendering and
simulation because that's a very easy
thing to paralyze and send out yeah but
a lot of this the the core design
solutions are stalled desktop you know
single user single threading even
working and you know those solutions
will hopefully get modernized and
and I think that will lead to another
level of productivity and we talk to
this comes a lot about generator design
but that's sort of a more advanced
design mechanism it's only really
possible through you know working with
the cloud and having sort of a very
highly scalable computational resource
at your disposal yeah yeah
and hopefully that gets democratized
more people around the world definitely
looking like it's going in that
direction back yes and no right yes as
in its it's now accessible like you
don't know long I have to build your own
yeah a data center but also in a way no
because now the quality of design really
depends to some degree on how much
you're waiting to spend on the computer
for it oh yeah right sure that's there's
that side of it too so yes I think
overall the trend is definitely positive
and obviously computing it gets ever
cheaper and ever more affordable but
it's no longer you know what can I come
up with but how much am I willing to
spend on it did yeah yeah there has been
a trend of the rise of civilization that
the more money that you can sometimes
spend on something the higher of a
quality that that product can be that
then can go out into the market and make
more to make you more money yeah
and then last question is what would you
say is a important skill for kids and
their parents to develop in the 21st
century
what is an important skill I found what
has been my sort of my driver at least
and I'm not sure why that translate but
it's really been an increase it e-book
technology how does it work and you know
I was always trying to play around with
these things and exposing myself
continue to expose myself to new
software and also machinery just to
really be sort of flexible and I mean
being able to you know be comfortable
and all of those things and I found this
is also way even now as you say your
your starting points for 18 years now
and in this business it's a way to keep
fresh and even beyond being a child like
how do you how does it so be be
interesting as well by trying to do new
things all the time we're trying to keep
it fresh right and I think it comes
natural to I think nearly all kids is to
wander about the world and you know just
let them let them try things out yeah
yeah you heard it here first keep it
fresh yeah I love it I love it this has
been a lot of fun thanks for coming on
the show Robert I appreciate it it's
been really enlightening there's a lot
to still learn and unpack check out the
links below for Roberts work also check
out the links below to Co Fez also give
us your thoughts in the comments below
we'd love to hear from you about what we
talked about in this conversation go
share with other people as well support
the artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in you can find all of
simulations links below and go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon peace